welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host
in this video we're breaking down
westworld season 4 episode 1. the latest
entry is extremely complex and filled
with a lot of hidden details easter eggs
and references to the prior seasons
there's also a ton of theories that i
have for what's going on and how the
character at the end has managed to come
back now we open much in the same way
that the third season did in that we
watched an extremely rich man being
taunted by a host until they did what
the host wanted them to we discovered
that he was an abusive wifebeater and
though the stories aren't exactly the
same they do share some similarities we
joined a cartel leader and learned that
they took over the hoover dam with the
rest of his gang as with most westworld
openings we start with the character
getting ready and here he heads out to
meet none other than the man in black
the cartel senior talks about how much
of a nice guy william is and as we
learned in the previous seasons the guy
he actually was it was only when he got
to the park that the darker side came
out of him and he turned unrecognizable
he'd set up several charitable
foundations in the real world which
guests even thanked him for but he was
such an evil guy his wife ended her own
life when she saw what he'd been up to
he also arrives in the same vessel that
sorak used to travel in when he'd hover
above humanity judging and deciding the
fates of all if he cast your mind back
to the ending of the last season we had
a post-credits scene in which he arrived
at dallas headquarters located in dubai
here he was seemingly killed by a
replica of himself which this version
that arrives seems to also be now if you
cast your mind back to the previous
season then you'll remember that william
lost some of his fingers and at the end
of season 3 he wore a glove that covered
this wound as this version gets off the
drone we can see that he doesn't have
this but he has all his fingers showing
that this is indeed a host i actually
binged all three seasons in the lead up
to this new one and though we don't get
any answers as to who exactly this
doppelganger is i do have my theories
now you might remember that william had
been testing a way to immortalize people
in host bodies by copying their minds
this was seen through james delos but
unfortunately he didn't make it past the
fidelity phase which was put in place to
see if they truly replicated someone and
could be released i have a theory that
this copy might have been the william
version of that and unlike james he
passed this crucial part he also says at
one point a very important line about
the dam have you seen it before
when i was a kid
road trip with my parents
hasn't changed a bit
this sticks out because these column
bodies retain the memories of the person
that they were duplicates of the
entirety of westworld was set up with
implants in the hearts that scanned
someone's brain and this made a copy of
them this was later used by rehoboam to
map out the world and plot courses for
humanity however it also duplicated
their entire brains and him having
childhood memories could further point
to this the hail copy in season two and
three didn't because she was just
dolores ryaza seems like it might be a
genuine copy of william either way one
thing that we saw at the end of the
third season was a lab full of hosts
being built and this could explain why
there are several characters returning
in this entry most notably teddy he
ended up ending himself in season 2 and
he was completely absent for the last
one however he's back now along with a
number of other older hosts so
potentially hellorus ended up
resurrecting him with william as her
number two this could be used as a way
to manipulate the original dolores and
we even see him saving her at the end of
the episode in the park her side quest
was started by her dropping a can which
was then picked up by someone and this
then started the loop with them this is
actually used later on in the episode
with the mysterious character she meets
potentially it's all set up as a way to
manipulate her by hail but we'll discuss
this later on in the video now at the
dam we get some hints to the plan that's
going on william wishes to buy in order
to obtain the data banks in information
that was stolen by what i believe was
the original hail this contained the
aforementioned copies of everyone's
brain who visited the park along with
the data on how the hosts were created
this isn't confirmed in the entry but
william does refer to the person who
stole them as being a she and that she's
dead in season 3 we discovered that hale
was working alongside sorak and she of
course died in the park and was copied
by dolores huda hail's death the data
can't be opened or decrypted and he says
that he just wants to keep it there
there's also another thing that it
clearly houses judging by the trailers
but i'll talk about this later on in the
video in case you don't want future
parts of the season spoiled now this
scene also gives us a rough timeline
with william mentioning that the data
was stolen eight years ago seven years
is also mentioned several times as being
when season three happened so this gives
us a rough idea of the events now
there's also a pattern on the floor that
looks like it's somewhat based on the
maze which has some significance in this
entry the cartel end up turning him down
and he gives this badass warning show me
this love of concrete today
or
or you give it to me for nothing
tomorrow gonna tell you guys you either
subscribe today or you might subscribe
tomorrow now moving on the boss then
returns home to find a swarm of flies
which of course bears a lot of symbolism
these flies very much represented a
fault in the programming as the hosts
were not built to swap them away and
thus they caused issues dolores did swap
one away at the end of the first episode
and thus she remained in her loop the
flies also bear symbolism and dreams
namely one breaking three of the
confines that one finds themselves in
though we don't know exactly what's
going on here the cartel boss collapses
and he wakes up almost as if it's from a
dream and see i told you there was some
symbolism there would you mean it to
reach now similar to how the hosts went
wild and attacked their masters he does
too though there's clearly something off
with him i don't believe that he's a
host and yet somehow william has managed
to program him into not only killing
them but also himself from here we
curtail the titles and this time we see
new graphics of the tower which several
characters discuss in this entry and
it's also what the lamp posts are model
after now the host in this opening is
also important on a symbolic level keep
keep using that word because it's
westworld and it's it's highbrow
entertainment and normally in the
credits it sinks into the fluid whereas
here it's rising out of it this is
showing the quote rise of the machines
and high bro stuff i'm telling you you
wouldn't pick that up if you you weren't
with me so stick with me and there's
also several clips of people stuck
inside cylinders circular almost
loop-like because it's symbolic anyway
it's a west world it's a west world it's
a west world it's a west world
now from here we go to dolores waking up
this is iconography that's popped up at
several points throughout the series and
we of course had it appear with the
characters in the first episode maeve
also did it when she took focus later on
in the season and in season 3 we got a
shot similar to this when she escaped
the simulation there was then caleb who
also did it in the series and it's often
set up as a way to introduce us to
either a character or a new version of
them this scene is shot extremely
similar to her entrance in the first
episode with her getting out of bed and
going through the house
at this time she's in the real world and
living in an apartment with her roommate
she's changed her hair colour and name
to christina which evan rachel woods
described as being a completely
different kind of dolores to what's come
before she's much more vulnerable and
whereas the prior version was ready to
kill everyone due to white being part of
her personality yeah she's sort of a
damsel in distress we get a subtle nod
at the park when her roommate asks her
whether she prefers white or black shoes
and this was of course married in the
hat choice that all the guests were
given she has several missed calls and
this is thought to potentially be a bot
which wouldn't be the first time a
character was revealed to be one hey
we're not having that caleb also got
calls from bots in the first season and
them doing this telemarketing thing is
common even if we know that's not what's
really going on here she also has this
strange earring that we later see her
boss also wearing at the end of the
episode we see this allows her to log
and record stories and she ends up
taking it off showing that she's no
longer tied to her job as dolores exits
her apartment we also see the word
warehouse behind the tree which is a
nice little play on how she and the
other hosts of course came from one
dolores is also wearing a similar color
code to the dress that she had on in the
park as for the world seems much happier
now that everyone has escaped their
loops however we see with caleb that
people very much wonder whether things
have actually changed there's the
automated driverless cars that we saw
pop-up in the last season and she passes
a homeless man who also mentions the
tower
can you see it
can you see it
he asks if people can see it possibly
meaning that filters have been put on
people so that it's invisible we saw in
season 3 how this was done in the case
of caleb so that he believed he was
assassinating certain targets that were
foreign enemies when really they were
just american citizens interestingly
dolores is now a video game story author
and she works at olympiad entertainment
this idea of video games and story lines
is laird throughout this episode and we
even get a cover of video games by lana
del rey it's you it's you the video's
for you so if you enjoy hit hit the
thumbs up
now the word olympiad actually derives
from the olympic games and it means the
four-year interval between them olympus
was also the home of the gods and if
it's true that dolores is writing the
stories of people in the real world then
she would very much be classed as one
interestingly the episode is called
auguries and this has ties to both omens
and prophecies dolores could very much
be seen as being able to read into this
as she can potentially predict people's
stories and how things will go a video
game company they just want her doing
sex and violence much like the park but
dolores she wants to sit about writing
stories at allegories for her and her
father abernathy dolores was at her
happiest when she was stood on the porch
waiting with him for teddy to return she
brings up how she's much better at
writing stories for npcs which is
because she was one whereas the guests
were the players we learned she wrote a
previous story about someone who lost
everything and this ended in bloodshed
in which everyone died again riffing on
clear metaphors of characters in the
park we then cut to the wilderness to
find maeve hiding out should have just
done a dolores and dyed your hair and
then no one would have recognized you
for about seven years however we see her
living this solitary lifestyle and
basically doing a world from breaking
bad she begins to meditate and sees
flashes of her daughter as well as the
maze you also get cuts of hector and his
death and i think he'll probably be
brought back as a way to manipulate her
along with clementine a favorite saying
about the new world is also dropped in
this is the new world
and in this world
you can be whoever the [ __ ] you want
bitter swearing there now she and caleb
ended up taking down sorak and his
forces after they inserted dolores mind
into rehoboth this could explain why she
carries the foresight to be able to
write people's stories as that machine
of course used an algorithm to protect
them we discover that she and caleb
traveled out to the original rehoboam
that was shown earlier in season 3 and
that they destroyed it caleb was badly
injured at it and these shots were
reminiscent of his friend dying in the
previous season stop it's theory time
now they obviously show that he
seemingly dies in the scene right but
that tension is immediately stripped
away in the next one with caleb's return
it's weird that they did this and i have
a theory if you will that this might
actually be caleb's death and that he
could have put his mind into a host like
what holloras did with william however
those cheeky buggers at westworld they
know we like our theory time so they
might have done this on purpose to make
us guess that he's dead due to the
similarities to the third season and
also our need to pick apart every single
thing in the world the west world if you
will anyway that's it and uh theory time
every time
[Music]
ends up causing a blackout in the town
which alerts william and co to her
location she of course had advanced
enough to the point where she could
control machines and this is actually
how she escaped sorak overpowering her
in season three could to caleb still
work in construction like how he was in
the third season whereas in that he had
a robot buddy though yeah he's got
another human because we discover all
the machines were scrapped guess it's
difficult to trust them after one's just
tried to murder everyone and this lip
service paid to the seven year
anniversary they won their freedom but
he's still stuck in the same job not
advancing at all and basically still
doing the same loop this is shown by the
shot of him sitting on the edge of the
skyscraper which mirrors the one from
the first season in which he sat on the
girder this was of course a nod to the
workers sat on top of one titled lunch
atop a skyscraper he goes to meet his
daughter yeah he'd have to have had her
before he became a host if we're right
with the theory time but turns out he's
training her to shoot against her
mother's wishes on the wall at his home
we see a parody of the banksy painting
with a machine controlling a human who's
controlling a drone this is symbolic
because rehoboam controlled humanity and
they controlled the hosts there's also
my brain my choice which is of course a
play on the saying my body my choice
brain is crossed out because rahul bomb
used to be a machine that would control
the destiny of humanity maeve travels
out toward his goodies which is a real
shop so eh learns something new every
day now after learning her quote-unquote
friends are in town she decides not to
bury the hatchet and heads out to take
them on they are led by colonel brigham
who you might recognize as being from
the second season he was a high ranking
member of the confederators and again
this shows that william is adapting
hosts from the park maeve ends up
standing in the truck with a can of
propane in the back which he shoots in
order to make it explode this was
something that we saw being used as a
tactic in the park when william and
dolores sent in a dead man on the back
of a horse filled with explosives that
they then shot and blew up she ends up
scanning brigham's memories and as we
learn in season 1 a host memory is
perfect this is why dolores had such
vivid flashbacks to the point that she
couldn't tell what was real and what
wasn't and maeve scans through his data
looks we see william and also a
mysterious mana dimension tried slowing
down the footage to see who this is but
i can't quite make them out later on
though maeve talks about william being
interested in the senator out in
california so potentially this could be
who that is now dolores returns home and
she gets called out by maya to prepare
for her date she hears a noise outside
and sees a picture of the maze likely
left behind by teddy the date is a bit
blah bit like one of those where you're
bored and just going through the motions
like my marriage having that and she
refutes the point that the background
characters in the games are just cannon
fodder obviously referring to the park
and not only is she disappointed with a
date she's also disappointed with
reality dolores wanted to do nothing but
escape the park and be free but she's
realized life ain't all it's cracked up
to be he mentions tabs at several points
and we saw these in the third season as
being common drugs these had the ability
to alter one's mind state such as the
one that made kayla hallucinate movie
soundtracks after she leaves she gets a
phone call from peter and he also
mentions the tower this could be sending
out signals from what may be dolores or
it could be hail remember that they both
came from the same code and those people
could end up getting the pair confused
if elorus ended up building a tower that
sends out signals showing people their
plans mapped out by rehobem it could
potentially send them insane he states
that he lost his job and wife and that
she made him and the others do bad
things he says they're part of a game
and it is possible she's writing stories
that get picked up by the tower heard by
those involved and then these make them
slowly go insane got no idea what's
going on with it mate if i'm being
honest but it wouldn't be westworld if i
did and i hope this stuff so far will
make you forgive me now dolores is saved
by teddy and mirroring her attack we
also see one later happen to caleb and
his family this idea of parents reading
bedtime stories to their kids was seen
in arnold slash bernard's kid and also
hailing her son outside frankie comes
across a host that was part of the
bandit group from the first season
really weird seeing this guy back and
yeah sticking with the season 3 post
credit scene theory that that hale's
just sending them all out now he is
saved by maeve and she tells him about
william which is when they head out
turns out his paranoia was justified and
he very much bears the responsibility of
things going haywire in the morning
dolores wakes up goes through her
routine once more and she sees peter and
his own life dolores seems completely
shocked by this again making me think
that it has nothing to do with her he
asks if it's up to him or if she wrote
his death too is this up to me
what did you write this to this makes me
think that he's trying to show he
wonders if he even has any more choices
or if they've all been taken away that
night dolores goes out to her balcony
and she starts to write a new story this
is something that relates to frankie
maeve and caleb's wife along with her
again loved the video games music gave
me goosebumps and we closed out with
teddy so lots of things going on with
the ending and lots of theories to talk
about it's even possible that dolores
isn't actually in the real world and her
brain may be inside rehoboam or a
simulation which explains teddy's return
at the end of season 3 that's how he
left her and it would make sense with
everything being in a loop this would
explain why people are also stuck doing
certain things and how they can be told
how their lives will end this hints
towards the simulation when the group of
dudes talk about this being their first
time place is [ __ ] wild you believe
this is your first
this is similar to people entering the
park and the logo for olympiad also
looks very similar to the delos one we
know that there's an eight-year time
span that this story can fit into but
what if it goes beyond that and we're in
the hundred years that the dam can power
the service for potentially this version
of dolores could be far into the future
which will sync up with bernard's
timeline who we still don't know what
happened to this entire thing could be a
park simulation or absolutely nothing
and it's a big reach
also forgot to point out earlier that
the painting in dolores is home also
reflects her doing paintings in the park
sent that bit to my editors before i
realized so just easier banging it in
here at the end instead of having to
talk to people for one minute longer
than i already do because they're a
bunch they're a bunch of
chumps see you chump
now i want to talk about the trailer for
the show for the next part of the video
and i know some of you don't like me
just diving into this stuff so this is
your spoilery warning for what's to come
knowing it he's still here now in it we
see hale talking to william and she says
that they can control humanity now this
is retribution for them controlling the
hosts and it might completely debunk
what we said earlier in the video so
wasted your time there now she could
have the real one still and be
controlling him at the start of the
episode this would explain how they
controlled the cartel boss and the flies
may be some form of nano machine
so going off the deep end here with the
theories but we also see caleb getting
swarmed by them as well other important
shots in it feature the tower and we
also see william approaching the dam
which we see houses the sublime this is
very much the entrance to heaven for the
hosts and the data banks clearly store
that too and the fact that william can
see it also likely means that he's a
host anyway those are the main things
and i loved how this was very much a
soft reboot of the series again lots of
stuff in the past seasons gets really
convoluted and i know people will just
forget it so i like that they kind of
turn things back it was basically it was
a west world wasn't it when you think
about it because it had those great
character moments symbolism and also
something tease that that lets you just
run well with the fan theories really
enjoyed it for the first episode it was
a westworld and i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it below now we are running
competition right now and giving away
three copies of everything everywhere
all at once in the 15th of july and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode if you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
witness of the last one on screen right
now so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else that messes with your
head a bit then check out our brighton
of the umbrella academy season 3 and
that crazy ending we try to clear up
exactly what happens in it so if you
watched that and had questions then
definitely head over there right after
this without the way thanks for sticking
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time take care peace